when I was approximately nine weeks
pregnant with my first child I found out
I'm a carrier for a fatal genetic
disorder called tay-sachs disease what
this means is that one of the two copies
of chromosome number 15 that I have in
each of my cells has a genetic mutation
because I still have one normal copy of
this gene the mutation doesn't affect me
but if a baby is inherits this mutation
from both parents
if both copies of this particular gene
don't function properly it results in a
sex an incurable disease that
progressively shuts down the central
nervous system and causes death by age
five for many pregnant women this news
might produce a full-on panic but I knew
something that helped keep me calm when
I heard this bombshell about my own
biology I knew that my husband whose
ancestry isn't Eastern European Jewish
like mine had a very low likelihood of
also being a carrier for the tay-sachs
mutation well the frequency of
heterozygotes individuals who have one
normal copy of the gene and one mutated
copy is about one out of 27 people among
Jews of Ashkenazi descent like me in
most populations only one in about 300
people carry the tay-sachs mutation
thankfully it turned out I was right not
to worry too much my husband isn't a
carrier and we now have two beautiful
and healthy children as I said because
of my Jewish background I was aware of
the unusually high rate of tay-sachs in
the Ashkenazi population but it wasn't
until a few years after my daughter was
born when I created and taught a seminar
on evolutionary medicine at Harvard that
I thought to ask and discovered a
possible answer to the question why the
process of evolution by natural
selection
typically eliminate
harmful mutations so how did this
defective gene persist at all and why is
it found at such a high frequency within
this particular population the
perspective of evolutionary medicine
offers valuable insight because it
examines how and why humans evolutionary
past has left our bodies vulnerable to
diseases and other problems today in
doing so it demonstrates that natural
selection doesn't always make our bodies
better it can't necessarily but as I
hope to illustrate with my own story
understanding the implications of your
evolutionary past can help enrich your
personal health when I started
investigating tay-sachs using an
evolutionary perspective I came across
an intriguing hypothesis the unusually
high rate of the tay-sachs mutation in
Ashkenazi Jews today may relate to
advantages the mutation gave this
population in the past now I'm sure some
of you are thinking I'm sorry did you
just suggest that this disease-causing
mutation had beneficial effects yeah I
did certainly not for individuals who
inherited two copies of the mutation and
had a sex but under certain
circumstances people like me who had
only one faulty gene copy may have been
more likely to survive reproduce and
pass on their genetic material including
that mutated gene this idea that there
can be circumstantial circumstances in
which heterozygotes are better off might
sound familiar to some of you
evolutionary biologists call this
phenomenon heterozygote advantage and it
explains for example why carriers of
sickle-cell anemia are more common among
some African and Asian populations or
those with ancestry from these tropical
regions in these geographic regions
malaria poses significant risks to
health the parasite that causes malaria
though can only complete its life cycle
in normal round red blood cells
by changing the shape of a person's red
blood cells the sickle cell mutation
confers protection against malaria
people with the mutation aren't less
likely to get bitten by the mosquitoes
that transmit the disease but they are
less likely to get sick or die as a
result being a carrier for sickle cell
anemia is therefore the best possible
genetic option in a malarial environment
carriers are less susceptible to malaria
because they make some sick old red
blood cells but they make enough normal
red blood cells that they aren't
negatively affected by sickle cell
anemia now in my case the defective gene
I carry won't protect me against malaria
but the unusual prevalence of the sickle
of the tay-sachs mutation in Ashkenazi
populations may be another example of
heterozygote advantage in this case
increasing resistance to tuberculosis
the first hint of a possible
relationship between tay-sachs and
tuberculosis came in the 1970s when
researchers published data showing that
among the Eastern European born
grandparents of a sample of American
Ashkenazi children born with tay-sachs
tuberculosis was an exceedingly rare
cause of death in fact only one out of
these 306 grandparents had died of TB
despite the fact that in the early 20th
century TB caused up to 20% of deaths in
large Eastern European cities now on the
one hand these results weren't
surprising people had already recognized
that while Jews and non-jews in Europe
had been equally likely to contract TV
during this time the death rate among
non-jews was twice as high but the
hypothesis that these Ashkenazi
grandparents had been less likely to die
of TB specifically because at least some
of them were taya sex carriers was novel
and compelling the data hinted that the
persistence of the tay-sachs mutation
among Ashkenazi Jews might be explained
by the benefits of the
carrier in an environment were
tuberculosis with prevalent you'll
notice though that this explanation only
fills in part of the puzzle even if the
tay-sachs mutation persisted because
carriers were more likely to survive
reproduce and pass on their genetic
material why did this resistance
mechanism proliferate among the
Ashkenazi population in particular one
possibility is that the genes and health
of Eastern European Jews were affected
not simply by geography but also by
historical and cultural factors at
various points in history this
population was forced to live in crowded
urban ghettos with poor sanitation ideal
conditions for the tuberculosis
bacterium to thrive in these
environments where TB posed an
especially high threat those individuals
who were not carriers of any genetic
protection would have been more likely
to die this winnowing effect together
with a strong cultural predilection for
marrying and reproducing only within the
Ashkenazi community would have amplified
the relative frequency of carriers
boosting TV resistance but increasing
the incidence of tay-sachs as an
unfortunate side effect studies from the
1980s support this idea the segments of
the American Jewish population that had
the highest frequency of tay-sachs
carriers trace their descent to those
European countries where the incidence
of TB was highest the benefits of being
at a sex carrier were highest in those
places where the risk of death due to TB
was greatest and while it was unclear in
the 1970s or 80s
how exactly the tay-sachs mutation
offered protection against TB recent
work has identified how the mutation
increases cellular defenses against the
bacterium so heterozygote advantage can
help explain why problematic versions of
genes persist at high frequencies in
certain populations but this is only one
of the con
tribution x' evolutionary medicine can
make in helping us understand human
health as they mentioned earlier this
field challenges the notion that our
body should have gotten better over time
an idea that often stems from a
misconception of how evolution works in
a nutshell there are three basic reasons
why human bodies including yours and
mine remain vulnerable to diseases and
other health problems today natural
selection acts slowly there are
limitations to the changes it can make
and it optimizes for reproductive
success not health the way the pace of
natural selection affects human health
is probably most obvious in people's
relationship with infectious pathogens
we're in a constant arms race with
bacteria and viruses our immune system
is continuously evolving to limit their
ability to infect and they are
continuously developing ways to
outmaneuver our defenses and our species
is at a distinct disadvantage due to our
long lives and slow reproduction in the
time it takes us to evolve one mechanism
of resistance a pathogenic species will
go through millions of generations
giving it ample time to evolve so it can
continue using our bodies as a host now
what does it mean that there are
limitations to the changes natural
selection can make again my examples of
heterozygote advantage offer a useful
illustration in terms of resisting TB
and malaria the physiological effects of
the tay-sachs and sickle cell anemia
mutations are good take into their
extremes though they cause significant
problems this delicate balance
highlights the constraints inherent in
the human body and the fact that the
evolutionary process must work with the
materials already available in many
instances a change that improved
survival or reproduction in one sense
may have cascading effects that carry
their own risk evolution isn't an
engineer that starts from scratch to
create optimal solutions to individual
problems evolution
is all about compromise it's also
important to remember when considering
our body's vulnerabilities that from an
evolutionary perspective health isn't
the most important currency reproduction
is success is measured not by how
healthy an individual is or by how long
she lives but by how many copies of her
genes she passes to the next generation
this explains why a mutation like the
one that causes Huntington's disease
another degenerative neurological
disorder hasn't been eliminated by
natural selection the mutations
detrimental effects usually don't appear
until after the typical age of
reproduction when affected individuals
have already passed on their genes as a
whole the biomedical community focuses
on proximate explanations and uses them
to shape treatment approaches proximate
explanations for health conditions
consider the immediate factors what's
going on inside someone's body right now
that caused a particular problem
nearsightedness for example is usually
the result of changes to the shape of
the eye and can be easily corrected with
glasses but as with the genetic
conditions I've discussed a proximate
explanation only provides part of the
bigger picture adopting an evolutionary
perspective to consider the broader
question of why do we have this problem
to begin with what evolutionary medicine
calls the ultimate perspective can give
us insight into non immediate factors
that affect our health
this is crucial because it can suggest
ways by which you can mitigate your own
risk or that of friends and family in
the case of nearsightedness some
research suggests that one reason it's
becoming more common in some populations
is that many people today including most
of us in this room spend far more time
reading writing and engaging with
various types of screen than we do
outside interacting with the world on a
bigger scale in evolutionary terms this
is a recent change for most of human
evolutionary history
people use their vision across a broader
landscape spending more time in
activities like hunting and gathering
the increase in recent years in what's
termed near work focusing intensely on
objects directly in front of us for long
periods of time strains our eyes
differently and effects the physical
shape of the eye when we put all these
pieces together this ultimate
explanation for nearsightedness that
environmental and behavioral change
impact the way we use our eyes helps us
better understand the proximate cause
and an inescapable conclusion emerges my
mother was right I probably should have
spent a little less time with my nose in
a book this is just one of many possible
examples so the next time you or a loved
one are faced with a health challenge
whether it's obesity or diabetes an
autoimmune disorder or a knee or back
injury I encourage you to think about
what an ultimate perspective can
contribute understanding that your
health is affected not just by what's
going on in your body right now but also
by your genetic inheritance culture and
history can help you make more informed
decisions about predispositions risks
and treatments as for me I won't claim
that an evolutionary medicine
perspective has always directly
influenced my decisions such as my
choice of spouse it turned out though
that not following the traditional
practice of marrying within the Jewish
community ultimately worked in my favor
genetically reducing the odds of me
having a baby with tay-sachs it's a
great example of why not every set of
Ashkenazi parents should hope that their
daughter marries a nice Jewish boy more
importantly though the experience of
learning about my own genes taught me to
think differently about health in the
long run and I hope sharing my story
inspires you to do the same thank you
[Applause]